ブーブー sp to do とこの動画では8 a 語と英語と日本語両方使います
が最初は英語でその動画なよ言いますので後半が日本語に
ブーバーまでスキップしてへくださいああします are you doing
パーカーバーハーツコーン to accept youtube
パウダーフリー x スマート2オン
voodoo
voodoo ピン cars ファーレンカーズ
はぁいっちょインズ for mature に out to do this
free all for nes トーンベイビーサーバ if スペイド for
iphone
m ちゃん院2
ウェストずマークスパース取ってるしてい
se
stf 交通ゲットワースト a 252ハーフ系 s アーム
ダービーだ10 things to be so 4ウォンティング friday
頭がぁ
まあ健康キーボードこんなふうグッドワークスイージー
ブーツ en コプターぷ2枚 sr プレイキャンペーンオーバーレッツ
スパーキーボード doodle r rr experimento ウィンカー4
s 1タイピング夏
カーズ b to slow down スイング fenders プロジェクト
td 村
rta sng フューラー合う mede search 最近 to be
pou dou dou
re re you doing
fbk omc ios aser tome ニーズスター4パターン
voodoo
ターリー arere カーれペーパーレス
rear are you doing 強引 to do do mi プリ
soon
ペニー喉ウィザーズフラー me to do in 4 days for the
voodoo とパピカーズ
4イターイ21 den den with my teraseek
ヴィッカーズ枚 yenoff フェイグシーンステッカー
rino シューリング miks apps to do well テンション
restoran babes are you doing スウィングストーン
derb 所 ntn erek d 2 a 4 a 6フォーン4 s easy
to do in for hen オーナーパワーストーン
チェーンジョイン forever れ
my finger anest スターターそれがギタースティラー
voodoo
2で22勝サーフワゴン n da go in for a days
パイプチーンスティングアップロードウェアメイク
ber petit story in english in japanese
ウィッグ iso ウィングプロストローラー s クラフトワークバーを
bassline 頭のたーーーー swing
ハーモン ters えっウッド japanese フリース e 2ストーリーは
japanese plan to do
usd r パワーれ pou dou dou
あああーーカメ pedia
うんっ
ないあーソファラグビーファン forever ウォン
ポプリファンフューザーズ5ジェットソン1 f
プードゥルスパー
inverse english and japanese game パターン
依存
オーグードゥ
voodoo forever review bo enjoy ディ
カインド今天ターム3プリの up next
マントアーチーマン2ハードラー tx b 2 a フォームです
br in js あー
1009円 who do マーカー日本語で今
今までいったことちょっと日本語で言ってみますそのまぁちょっと水を飲みます
以前
2以前アップした動画の中で指の
なんだ指の痛みがあっあるって言う風に話してたと思うんですけれどもそれが悪化して
しまって今こうキーボードを使っているときに聴い
特に右側のシフトキーとかを打つときにかなり行きたいので
まあ
ケガをしていると言ってもいいでしょう
この怪我がさらに悪化してしまうと本当に仕事が出来なくなると思うので
もうすでに1回病院に行って
レントゲンとへ血液検査をしてもらったんですけれども異常なしっていうことで
おそらく神経の問題なんじゃないかなっていうふうに僕は思っています
なのでへ今度は今笑いを取りに行こうと思ってるんですけれども
a その子供たち僕はの双子の赤ちゃんがいるんですが
a 彼女たちがんでている間しか
なんだろその秒日に行けないので
俺をなんだろうその今までのワーク
仕事の過程だいぶ変わりますので
まぁ今後について
どうか悪かっ
っていう話をしていきたいと思っています
でまぁ今まではだいたいへ皆さんのご存知の通り
すいません
今音がしましたん
まあ日本語
で話しながら
姉子英語の字幕をつけてコミュに動画をアップしていたと思うんですけれども
この話す分については特に全然問題ないんですよね
気が全く関係ないんですがその編集をする時に本当に痛いので編集はちょっとできなく
なるっていうか
のはあの
極力編集パソコンキーボードを打つっていう作業できるだけしない日本にしていきたい
と思っているので編集しなくていいような動画を今後
ワープしていきたいなと思っていますなのでこのような動画とかへ
本当の音校質疑応答動画とかっていうのを
作っていきたいなと思っていますね以前に港へ
日本で働くことについての失業と
みたいな動画を作ったんですがえ
まあそれ以外の例えば日本でその
自分の
家の家系家系でいいのかなそのお金の使い方
どの銀行を使ったらいいかとかまあどう節約した方がいいかとかっていうのを
についてちょっと話をしてみたいなと思っています
まあか系以外のトピックも
いろいろについて話をしてみたいと思っていますのでまぁよかったらこれについて話し
てくださいというようなコメントを
投稿してください
でまぁそれを見て判断しますのでよろしくお願いします
で後何でしょうええええまあ日本語の
音声レッスンも行ってるんですがまっ例えば
このような本を使ったりとかしてるんですがまぁ
その角品の良い点と悪い点とかねまぁ
教材評価動画とかもう
して
アップしていきたいなと思っていますしまぁ自分のこの部屋のツアー
どうか
え
room つはじゃないんですけどオフィスツアーでいいですかね
の動画もアップだしていきたいなぁと思っていますし今までの動画
8多分打って変わっての感じの動画になると思いますので全然アリなんですけれども
ご了承ください
あとまたいいのかな
多分怪我についてへ
そうですねどのぐらい時間かかるかその直すのにどんくらい時間がかかるかっていうの
は全然わからないので
おそらく1ヶ月とか2ヶ月
ぐらいなんじゃないかなと勝手に思ってるんですけど
まあ
もっと時間かかるかもしれないしすぐに直せるかもしれないので
まあしばらくの間んわ
今までの動画はちょっとアップできないので
はいもう一度言いますがご了承下さいあとはいいのかの全部入ったのか
英語のほうがだいぶ分かったような気がするな
入ったのか
はい多分全部入ったと思いますそのパソコンキーボードを打つって言うのはあれなので
この動画のタイトルとか
その説明文とかもうできるだけ
少なめにしていきたいなと思っていますので
俺なんか
変に短いなとかも
思えば
原因がそのこの怪我なんです
なので入っ
以上だと思います
いいのかねほんと日本語の方はだいぶ3時間ような気がするなぁ
いいでしょうはいえ
また英語に変えます変わります
あー結果 seere ar japanese sony
シャーリーと25種あるエンター in japanese your
なんだろお前考え方
またちょっとニアムース1%者ピースワークウィーク
はいえちょっと話さなかった部分がありますのでその
僕のなんだろその考え方というか以前に色んな色んたんじゃなくて
鳥トリッキングトリッキングディスポーツをやってたんですがまぁ格闘技と体操が
混ざり合ったようなスポーツなんですが
その時にまあね骨の骨折とか
a 人体を破ったりとかしてて
草を取ってもへ
ジムに行って
練習をしてたんですよねでまぁここで何が言いたいかっていうと
ぽこ無理をする人間無理をするタイプの人間のんですよね
もので
まあそうしてしまったカラーが今
が大変だっていうのを学びましたので
この子のけががさらに悪化しないように
え
今までつ違ってもっと注意していきたい
生きていきたいなと思っていますので
はい
dvd アップと思いますアート英語にーかーレス perder see who
do japanese
ん
andengine bode iphone 4 s 4
ゲンティン personas 分ルードゥ
re you doing
マインド捨て身フィーリンカーン先軍4 s 5
点9件プリウスサポート4 s ピム tuono ん
皆さん
もう1回言いますが
今までとちょっと違う感じの動画を混合アップしていきたいなと思っていますので
今までのね
支援とかもえ
本当に
ありがたいと思っていますし今今後とも是非喉の皆さんにとっての
にとって a 面白いと思ってもらえるいただけるような動画を作っていきたいなと
思っていますので
えーちょっとアレなんですが今後ともよろしくお願いします
キャンペーン c はずだよなさようならん